did you know that every second you are
experiencing microwave radiation from
space that's right microwaves the same
radiation heating your leftovers is
what's heating the universe the first
time humans saw this cosmic radiation
was while channel surfing on our first
television sets we didn't know it then
but we were watching the oldest
radiation inside this radiation is our
history
it describes the conditions of the early
universe and today is the strongest
evidence for a hot Big Bang model let's
slow down to understand how all this
works we need to travel back in time one
month after the beginning of the cosmos
13.8 billion years ago less than a
second after the hot Big Bang the
universe underwent a period of massive
inflation during this period of
inflation everything grew by 60 e
foldings after this short-lived
inflation epoch the universe has
continued to expand and has become a
dense soup of particles about a billion
degrees Celsius that's roughly a million
times hotter than the Sun today so hot
that matter and energy are essentially
the same thing our universe soup it's
called the photon baryon fluid because
it's made of mostly photons and baryons
with a dash of electrons photons are the
light particles which carry the energy
of radiation they travel in the form of
waves short wavelengths carry high
energy long wavelengths carry less
energy
when a photon is radiated away it
retains information about the source
such as its temperature direction and
even its chemical composition they carry
this information until they interact
with matter which means that the photons
we detect today provide us with the
history of their origins baryons include
protons and neutrons which make up the
nucleus of the atom the atom is the
fundamental building block for all
matter the simplest atom hydrogen
requires one electron orbiting a single
proton but because the cosmos is so
small and hot the photons are energetic
enough to blast electrons out of orbit
thus no atoms are formed and nothing
matters the universe pretty much stays
is this hot cosmic soup for a while so
let's fast forward it is now 380,000
years later as the universe expands it
stretches the wavelength of photons
resulting in a distribution of energy
across space the dispersion of this
energy has caused the cosmic soup - cool
- about 3000 degrees Celsius roughly
half the temperature of the Sun today
since the photons are traveling with
longer wavelengths they are not
energetic enough to scatter off
electrons in orbit the photon baryon
fluid has evaporated let there be light
and matter this instant is recognized as
the surface of last scattering the first
light of the cosmos a snapshot of the
young universe photons can now move much
longer distances and carry the
information about this time further
electrons are free to orbit baryonic
nuclei forming the basic blocks of all
life as we move forward in time the
photon wavelength continues to stretch
at 100 million years matter condenses to
form stars at 600 million years our home
galaxy the Milky Way is born at eight
point six
in years the Sun forms giving birth to
our solar system today the universe is
13.8 billion years old it has continued
to expand and the photons of the early
cosmos have continued to stretch
becoming invisible low-energy microwaves
which are nearly radio waves in the year
1964 to scientists at Bell Labs detect
this radiation as noise in their radio
telescope after cleaning up the white
dielectric material bird poop they think
is interfering with their data they
discover this cosmic radiation is
constant from every direction in the sky
after a paper publication this apparent
noise from the sky is recognized as
remnant radiation from the earliest
observable moment in the evolution of
the universe a baby picture of the
cosmos called
the Cosmic Microwave Background this
radiation from the CMB is what heats the
empty voids of space to three degrees
above absolute zero two point seven two
five Kelvin today we know the CMB is the
heat radiation from the evaporation of
the early cosmic soup it is evidence
that the universe was once a hot dense
fluid that has been expanding we
interpret this as evidence of the Big
Bang but we don't know what happened
before this picture cosmologists
consider a number of origins for the
cosmos
based on this CMB radiation but the most
widely accepted model is the hot Big
Bang if the universe weren't expanding
we wouldn't be here and it would still
be a hot soup of energy and matter
you